BRIAN: WELCOME TO "ONE NATION."
I'M BRIAN KILMEADE.
IT'S THE RISE OF THE REASONABLE.
SOME OF THE MOST POWERFUL VOICES
IN AMERICA TODAY ARE POPULAR NOT
FOR WHAT THEY WERE KNOWN FOR IN
THE PAST, BUT FOR THEIR
REASONABLE TAKES IN MY VIEW.
AND THEY ARE LABELED
REASONABLE -- LABELED RADICAL
BECAUSE THEY ARE REASONABLE.
THEY HAVEN'T CHANGED OVER THE
YEARS, THE MEDIA HAS.
BUT PEOPLE ARE SICK OF IT, I
BELIEVE.
JOE ROGAN IS INSANELY POPULAR
EVEN WITH THE LEFT TRYING TO
CANCEL HIM.
>> WHEN I SAY SOMETHING STUPID,
I'M NOT THINKING ABOUT WHAT I'M
SAYING BEFORE I SAY IT.
I AM A CAGE FIGHTING COMEDIAN.
I AM NOT A RESPECTED SOURCE MUCH
INFORMATION EVEN FOR ME.
I TRY TO BE HONEST ABOUT WHAT
I'M SAYING.
>> BILL MAHER IS A LIBERAL AND
TODAY EVERYONE KIND OF LIKES
HIM, ESPECIALLY ON THE RIGHT.
>> I'M STILL THE UNMARRIED,
CHILDLESS, POT SMOKING LIBBER
TEEN I ALWAYS WAS.
YOU CAN'T ACUES ME OF MATURING.
IT'S NOT ME WHO CHANGED.
IT'S THE LEFT.
I WILL CALL THEM OUT.
BRIAN ARE'S HONEST HE HAS EVEN
COME OUT AGAINST THE LIBERAL
OUTCRY OVER FLORIDA'S EDUCATION
BILL.
>> AS ALWAYS WITH THIS STUFF
IT'S NOT LIKE THERE IS NO KERNEL
OF TRUTH THAT MAYBE KIDS THAT
YOUNG SHOULDN'T BE THINKING
ABOUT SEX AT ALL.
BRIAN: PEOPLE RESPECT THAT, AND
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN IS
RESPONDING TO THESE REASONABLE
PEOPLE, EVEN IF YOU DON'T AGREE.
JOE MANCHIN'S APPROVAL RATING
HAS SKYROCKETED 17% THE LAST
YEAR.
HE'S REASONABLE.
AND HE STOOD IN THE WAY OF JOE
BIDEN'S AGENDA BECAUSE IT HASN'T
BEEN REASONABLE.
>> I HAVEN'T CHANGED.
I LOOK FOR THE MODERATE MIDDLE.
THE COMMON SENSE THAT COMES WITH
THE MODERATE MIDDLE IS WHO I AM.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE EXPECT.
BRIAN: ELON MUSK GETTING HAMMERS
BY THE LEFT FOR HIS TAKEOVER OF
TWITTER.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE HE'S
CONSERVATIVES.
HE HAS NEVER BEEN.
HE JUST TELLS IT LIKE IT IS.
HE TWEETED I SUPPORTED OBAMA FOR
PRESIDENT BUT TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC
PARTY HAS BEEN TAKEN OVER MY
EXTREMISTS.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> ELON MUSK CALLED HIMSELF A
FREE SPEECH ABSOLUTIST.
THAT'S B.S.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S ABOUT FREE
SPEECH OF STRAIGHT WHITE MEN.
>> IF YOU OWN ALL OF TWITTER OR
FN  *, YOU DON'T OR FACEBOOK, YU
DON'T HAVE TO EXPLAIN YOURSELF.
>> PEOPLE AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
ARE MAKING DECISIONS THAT COULD
AFFECT THE FATE OF THE PLANET.
BRIAN: THE LIBERTARIAN SHOWS
HE'S MORE SANE THAN SQUAD.
THE LEFT SHOULD LOVE HIM.
REMEMBER TESLA?
THAT'S THE GREENEST VEHICLE IN
THE WORLD.
MAYBE THE BEST.
AS UNORTHODOXED AS HIS ANTICS
ARE, HE'S PROPOSING TRUE FREEDOM
OF SPEECH FOR THE FUTURE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA.
THEY HAVEN'T CHANGED OVER THE
YEARS, THEIR PARTIES HAVE.
BUT THEIR RISING POPULARITY SHOW
ME THE COUNTRY HAS NOT.
ARE WE FINALLY SNAPPING OUT O